meet the bearded crew Toronto dango
Matteo hey go Silvo and [ __ ] Greece
little boys right there
tell you what gentlemen I'm Chris Fido
dog beer club.com what is the dollar
beer club well you sure as hell won't be
receiving any [ __ ] razors from us to
demolish your manhood dollar beard clubs
launch video is a clear parody of what
dollar shave club did to launch their
company hi I'm Mike founder of
dollarshaveclub.com what is
dollarshaveclub.com well for $1 a month
we sent high-quality razors right to
your door had everything from similar
joke styles to similar camera angles
Malick's contra summer reporter with
BuzzFeed news and we're just pulling in
to Bloomington California right now to
be team behind dollar beard club like
many businesses these days dollar beard
got launched with the viral video and
like many we haven't requested them
since so we're going to go spend the day
with them and try to find out whether or
not their viral video is translated into
a real business so this is where the
magic happens this is where it all goes
down yeah grab a box in here
[Music]
it's a lot to manage what to keep on top
of yeah yeah it's definitely a lot to
keep on top well I've built an amazing
team that's in place that's able to
handle all this come you let somebody
operate to the best of their ability of
what they're good at it's been it lets
everyone else focus on what they're good
at I get to do video stuff a lot of
companies they'll have their viral
moment and then they'll sort of come
back to earth and then flatline yeah so
how did you keep growing hitting that
hard that many times kind of set a
standard where we weren't ever going to
flatline it's not like we went viral
selling boxes of Kleenex or or something
out there like we were literally
connecting the dots of all the bearded
guys in this world and I'll never get
tired of saying and even though I do it
all the time but when a bearded guy
passes a bearded guy in the street they
look at each other and there's this
underlying brotherhood there's this
sense of camaraderie so it looks like
there is a is a good amount of churn I
mean if I say some of these numbers four
months dollar beard club had been
telling BuzzFeed news that they were
running a real business that the numbers
look great but it wasn't enough to take
them on their word
I will say it's pretty remarkable that
you're allowing a reporter to come in
and look at your back-end accounting
systems seems like it's paying on you a
little bit it is but but here's why I
feel good about it the startup world in
the startup community I've spent my
whole career in Silicon Valley right
they've gone off the deep end on the
other way fabricating things making up
stuff sorry can we talk revenue so
revenue were at about a 1.1 million a
month run rate right now
cumulatively we've done about 9.5
million if you make one poem you're like
how much are you spending yeah I mean
we're not we're a startup right yeah
we're reinvesting so yeah we're we could
be profitable if we wanted to just stall
out and not grow but yeah we're
reinvesting everything back into the
business I'm pretty sure Amazon still
breaks a part right well boys I think
that was a pretty dumb meeting today
with everything we covered while the new
content of growth campaigns how good
customer services is rolling and just
knowing we're about to come off on a
heavy summer now this is big this is
bigger than beard oil or balm or
moustache wax those are staples and
those keep your beard looking damn
healthy and great but this is a
lifestyle brand because it's a lifestyle
a few weeks after our meeting with
Dollar beard Club Dollar Shave Club that
company that it parodied in the initial
video sold to Unilever for 1 billion
dollars Chris toy coast CEO of dollar
beer club sent BuzzFeed news a text
saying his year one numbers were better
in Dollar Shave club's year one numbers
and he expects his year two numbers to
be even better than theirs this time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]